Minecraft.
You might not have played it, but you've most certainly heard of it.
Released to the public back in 2009 in embryonic form,...
...the game has been in development ever since,...
...with players regularly receiving free software updates...
...that continue to add exciting new features and functionality.
But what is it?
Well, it's whatever you want it to be.
After being dropped into a randomly generated 3D world,...
...in which everything is created from a range of identically-sized cubes,...
...it's up to you what you choose to do.
A huge part of the game's appeal is its breadth.
If you get bored with one area of gameplay,...
...there's many others to keep you amused.
It would take hours, if not days, to go into all of them in detail,...
...but for now, here's a quick overview of some of the main things you can get up to.
One of the first things you want to focus your efforts on is setting up a base...
...from which you can go on your adventures.
Building a structure that protects you and your possessions from the game's many threats...
...is a great way to get the hang of the basic mechanic of gathering and placing materials.
Alongside this, you'll create yourself some basic tools...
...such as axes, shovels and pickaxes to make the job easier,...
...plus a crafting table and furnace to make the most of the resources you'll find.
But where will you find them?
Well, you might choose to go exploring and find a cave,...
...where there'll hopefully be some rare materials to mine, such as gold, iron and diamonds.
You'll need to keep alert though, as various baddies known as "mobs"...
...may have other plans for you.